you know somebody watch Game seven of
the finals trying to imitate the king
that time with the slide oh no mark he
almost got leave it went straight up and
down was kind of leaning from one side
to the other Booker and be there to say
absolutely
slide of Defense Booker sees daylight
not too long
indeed says no indeed be part of
primarily a spot-up shooter by and be as
he rose to the occasion against Terrell
Martin's it's Bayliss who gets beat and
sends him right to Joelle and that's all
ball delivers when you need it and be
thinking three Joelle and he throws it
down here's the thought process again do
I clean this pump fake no I'm gonna
explode and exploit one more look at it
barn don't doubt the cloud with fewer
personal fouls per game that's any other
NBA team just under 17 yrs seller and
then beat meta Matt the top Wow in a
play by Joe Allenby it goes out of
bounds and it'll belong to the Sixers I
gotta take a look at that again let's
see this Zeller thinks he's got a wide
open look
oh my goodness head at the rim no foul
no contact that's a grateful act but
extend elevate Doba works it for a terry
free on the block by Stauskas great
front of a sixer bench and feed leaking
and he comes down - JoEllen be his
second bucket he's got a double-double
ten and ten and the Sixers down one
under a minute to play here in the third
is the defense first great challenge by
big Dario gets the rebound to pass up
ahead
and it's gone here on the 3rd and feeds
thinking three almost turned it over and
harden makes the steel crossed over
cotton unbelievable play goes up and
gets it knocks it off the rim
[Applause]
by coming Timbers oh boy sixes lost
Collins they were lucky he did field it
cleanly and feed their to throttle
babbit underneath here it is a kin
Skyview there's the block from behind
and deep thinking three the veteran date
west on him McConnell could he save it
he did Simmons tracking Livingstone play
by and B to talk about getting back on
defense there's the turnover balls try
to get over to TJ no dice Ben comes in
Joe well starting 5:30 local time 8:30
of course in the east
sharukh and throwing it down
that's a good way to get yourself going
isn't it the best way is the last play
between Dario and Joelle again we talked
about when your name doesn't get called
well when you see the ball go through
the hoop and your game starts clicking
you can see your chest pop out you start
[Applause]
DeAndre Jordan
you're talking about a tenured now it
was a great fake but you're talking
about a ten-year vent gone for the fake
I don't see Lucas my lead a pump fake Oh
someone bit and to finish by two one
here it is again you got to stay on the
crowd though jump DeAndre cuz this just
might happen
top of the show and in Philadelphia with
those incredible fans indeed wow what a
play by an beat-making sharidan charge
into Lopes great feet to teach this this
a big guy with skills who Euro step
excuse me to Brook Lopez with the finish
sound goodness Lakers have scored nine
of last 12 points to retake the lead MV
41 Lookout League watching this this is
truly dreamlike Akeem Olajuwon tight
footwork nine in this one shot clock is
unplug
be there to smother damian lillard not
your typical block what's the well
recover back personal bounce six are
suddenly by eighteen and be his third
block in the first half he runs the
floor with simmons and finishes what he
take a look at the sixes on defense we
talked about the great rotation
defending without fouling took that
right back to the big boy he's running
the court for you
McGirt again his own mess by and be
absorbed
he will make you look mad about that
instead of Duncan it he gets smeared up
against the backboard
Sarek store be
and beat acid side and cut it to throws
it down
timeout okay see it's a four-point lead
for Philly I mean left hand on the money
Joe lmv Westbrook looking for George
News denied Westbrook crossover drives a
lane blocked by a bee ball knocked out
of bounds
sixer ball
spectacular defensive play from Joe
Allenby they're going to review the out
of Bounce there's the black impede with
the three nine seconds to go it's a
one-possession game now this is I mean
this is from 3540 feet here yeah that's
what they're calling a violation I guess
if you see the mismatch you have to be
ready to help
[Applause]
14-point able to maintain their lead how
by executing a Meccano they leave them
open for another three and here is Van
Vleet too much time to think about it in
my opinion ha JoEllen bead marvelous
hustle and potal up to the trainer
looking at him that's getting after it
and that's to well the good news is he's
getting after it here in the fourth
quarter making that kind of a run
Simmons back to you the way let's put
this over for his show and go and feed
detonates on Westbrook and stairs him
down Russell knows a thing or two about
going with that kind of violent force to
the back whistle and a foul gonna go
against the 76ers and indeed let Russ
know that he just yakked one on him with
the staredown remember in the first
meeting a triple overtime win by the
Thunder so good last year he's improved
his numbers even this year before last
[Applause]
and then slams OH
one of one look at JoEllen be a
corkscrew move he gets by proud and
hammers it home for the world team so
aggressively
and be rolling in and slamming for -
JoEllen be
but to do everything quickly that time
traveled but then the Pacers had an
answer of nine straight and kept
separation ever since impedes slamming
it down
compliments of Ben Simmons his ninth
assist the right separates those two
right now Redick who has led the NBA in
free-throw percentage various times
during the year
otherwise that's just a great screen for
Marco we've seen JJ in that position
that is versatile your son certainly
that Wow
he's better than anybody else out on the
floor try and stop me
to one with the finish big fella 16 and
suddenly is high man the game after a
slow start coming tonight Elisha gonna
be heading
[Applause]
Sixers with active hands robber playing
the passing lanes a little bit of public
the pass up ahead Jojo with the
enthusiasm after the business indeed
misses the second six point game
Crockett on the push a major rejection
draaga thought he was hit on the awful
and bead play
Gordon's going hard and yeah I tell you
what a heckuva that's a heck of a block
but bye-bye to Helen well it's the
unwillingness and the inability as well
turnover though by Boston ah Simmons in
transition
[Applause]
this is no phantom of the process this
is a man of the process
goodness
so it's a two-point lead for Boston
three and a half to go and B drive gets
half Horford
[Applause]
feet off the deck against the elite
defender yes sir he sees the clothes on
the top side says paint that out Horford
you can't check
built four and five guys more
three-point shooting more spacing are we
are more of an international game
because of the addition of the eyes
reporters did not get away throughs the
second try
here comes Simmons between them thank
you to our TMT Studios sometimes you and
be throwing it down and a foul Joelle
and bead release is some tension there's
maybe some frustration on that she's an
opening and attacks the rim look out the
load the skirt started a game will they
finish it and be Knights give up Simmons
who throws it down at four Joelle a
career-high ninth assist and fee that's
Dudley taking a tumble
took it back in slammed for to we have a
techno being called as well as then be
taking a page butler nice hustle
McConnell thinking three sixes to over
fresh 14 and be
[Applause]
spotty but this time it's the diminutive
Bert's on him with the reverse dribble
making it look at blur the defense my
Hartford and the steel Tatum made great
recovery by JoEllen Mead after break
Barack I'll keep an eye on this
seconds HD Papa Schadt cut not the way
there by the Rockets on us here comes
Harden with
[Applause]
and that's it has been a haunting by
envy look at the block here by envy
which is beautiful
you guys you want your big running in
transition but it's the post play watch
how he gets up has words for the MVP
here there's the block and here's the
look in stare down there's Looney with
the board now indeed looks like Chandler
got a piece of that second try by Looney
good pass
Maxon bull JoEllen bead a bang going
windmill put him in the slam dunk
contest slits by Harris onto Murray
Beasley on the baseline rising up and by
a Meade o'clock he slipped it
[Applause]
and the puckett here would be huge for
the Sixers already up six and be playing
with it more on the shot clock to pull
up closing time for Jojo we're higher in
the standings he'd be higher in the MVP
race that is twice on the pipes
emphatically mr. Beasley
[Music]
[Applause]
take a look at this again this is an
awkward shot I don't think he was ready
for this but how about that was some
sickness right there Scott this is
Maghrib a tennis recoups it Joella feed
a minute to go in the opening for bade
weight was created because of that pick
and roll up top and that's the hard part
about getting quite Leonard a couple
minutes rest that shot won't count on a
foul by Lauer to stop the pass break
blocks it well no you know but Philly
has live sports the song on the poll by
by and beed rejecting Ibaka at the RIT
power forward coming with both hands on
the ball 16 point Philadelphia lead
inside by the quarter
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content